le pardon est la plus belle fleur de la
victoire proverbe arabe
plus que jamais d'actualité pour
l'américain edward snowden il aura fallu
attendre huit ans pour qu'une cour de
justice européenne reconnaisse
officiellement son travail
en 2013 le lanceur d'alert dénoncé les
agissements du gouvernement comme
ducation herbe quarters l' agence de
renseignement britanniques pour ses
pratiques de surveillance allant à
l'encontre des droits de l'homme ce
mardi la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme a approuvé ces accusations et
considérer que l'interception massive de
communication en ligne opérée par cette
agence est est illégale
afin de minimiser le risque d'abus du
pouvoir d'interception en masse la cour
estime que le processus doit être soumis
à des garanties de bout en bout que
l'interception en masse doit faire
l'objet d'une autorisation indépendante
dès le départ lorsque l'objet est la
portée de l'opération sont définis et
que l'opération doit faire l'objet d'une
supervision et d'un contrôle indépendant
a posteriori en clair le gouvernement
britannique a abusé de son pouvoir dans
plusieurs affaires d'espionnage en ligne
tout d'abord dans son processus
d'interception de données selon les
conclusions de l'enquêté à
l'autorisation était donnée par un homme
politique et non par un organisme
indépendant
d'autre part les termes de recherche qui
serait signalée par l' agence
d'espionnage n'avait pas été inclus dans
la demande de mandats et les termes de
recherche liés à des individus par
exemple des noms adresses emails et
numéro de téléphone n'avait pas été
autorisée en interne avant leur
utilisation
ce qui signifie une violation de
l'article 8 de la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme
il protège le droit au respect de la vie
privée et familiale du domicile et de la
correspondance
le royaume uni a donc été condamnée par
la cod h
une décision de justice salué sur
twitter par plusieurs médias à commencer
par l'ancien rédacteur en chef du
guardian alan rusbridger reloue le rôle
d'edward snowden sans lequel rien
n'aurait été possible
le lanceur d alerte 6 lui a répondu avec
l'humilité qu'on lui connaît cela a pris
beaucoup de temps mais il s'avère que
snow dunn avait raison
sans journaliste pour raconter
l'histoire le public ne l'aurait pas su
sans les avocats des droits de l'homme
qui défend des ce public les tribunes on
ne s'en serait pas soucié sans ces
tribunaux les politiciens le nierait
toujours je n'aurais pas pu faire sa
seule une victoire modeste mais ô
combien importante pour big brother
watch
l'organisme de renseignements à
l'origine de la plainte contre le
gouvernement communications headquarters
sur twitter la directrice de cette même
organisation qui lutte pour les libertés
civiles et la protection de la vie
privée appelle les dirigeants européens
à protéger edward snowden pour sa
défense désintéresser des droits de
l'homme exilé en russie depuis 2013
le lanceur d'alerté toujours accusé de
haute trahison par le gouvernement
américain et risquent une peine de 30
ans de prison pour espionnage notamment
pour avoir dévoilé elle le scandale des
écoutes de la nsa et de la cia à
plusieurs reprises et dans snow elle a
d'ailleurs demandé l'exil politique à la
france notamment à emmanuel macron en
2019 j'ai demandé l'asile en france en
2013 sous françois hollande
évidemment j'aimerais beaucoup que
monsieur macron m'accorde le droit
d'asile
une demande restée vaine car contrarier
l'ami américain peut-être très mal
en tout cas cette décision de justice
pourrait peut-être changer la donne et
la perception que le pays des lumières à
des douars foden mais pour cela il
faudra peut-être encore attendre
l'échéance présidentielle de 2000 20